l'artillerie blindées allemandes
tout au long de son temps de
commandement rhein scuderia n'a toujours
été convaincus qu'une division bien
organisés et réellement efficaces devait
disposer de manière organique de sa
propre artillerie autopropulsés avec la
même capacité de projection que les
penseurs et immédiatement disponibles
pour fournir un tiers d'appui à la
demande
cette idée de goût derrière n'aurait pu
voir le jour au moment du réarmement de
l'allemagne quand des années 30 mais
cela ne restera qu'un rêve tandis qu'une
propagande subtil et sophistiqué est
chargé au sein du grand public
le mythe d'un troisième rail immensément
puissant la réalité était toute
différente et le programme d'armement
bien que très large n'avait que peu de
profondeur
adolf hitler voulait la guerre mais ils
n'arrivent pas l'intention de soumettre
à l'allemagne à une répétition du
conflit qui avait causé sa perte lors de
la grande guerre même le programme de
réarmement faisait l'objet d'une
propagande exagéré comparé à son
financement réel et peu de personnes
était consciente de la pression exercée
sur l'économie du pays
avant même que la guerre n'est commencé
lorsque la guerre commence à hitler
souhaitait un conflit rapide et net le
conflit qui débuta le 1er septembre 39
10 l'allemagne prépare à rien sauf à une
guerre très courte
le corps blindé était certainement le
plus à même de supporter un conflit
majeur
les chars moyens qui constituait la base
de la doctrine d'emploi des blindés pour
la guerre sortait à peine des chaînes de
montage la cadence de production des
penseurs et et basse ll est le rester
plusieurs années encore après le début
de la guerre
à ce stade il n'était pas envisageable
que les panzer division dispose de leur
pop art irish nier alors que les sharks
et celles ci devaient appuyer n'était
pas encore produit en nombre suffisant
la préparation se reflétait également
dans la dotation en camions de
ravitaillement lors de la mise en place
de l'opération barbarossa les
détachements de transport était équipé
le véhicule prélevée sur toutes les
armes et que l'allemagne avait vaincu la
modernité n'était qu'une façade et l'art
syrie en était le meilleur exemple
hormis un petit nombre de canons tractés
par des semis chenilles est capable de
suivre les panzer division pour assurer
leur appui direct la grande majorité des
pièces d'artillerie étaient tirées par
des chevaux 3 millions de chevaux furent
déployés en russie par la wehrmacht
tandis que les tendons les muscles
accomplissez les grandes marches dans
l'arrière pays soviétiques durant la
première phase ii barbarossa le
spectacle des colonnes et des armes
transportées à dos de cheval faisant
mouvement vers l'est rappelé à celui des
troupes allemandes sur le même chemin
dans la russie de 1918
bien que l'économie germanique sur le
point de connaître une remarquable
expansion au cours de l'année qui allait
suivre permettant l'achat massif d'armes
goudé rien hormis jamais la quantité qui
l'estimé nécessaire
le tout premier penseur jaeger
faiblement blindés étaient à canon
automoteur antichar monté sur le châssis
du penseur 1b engagé pour la première
fois en 1940 il était construit autour
du canon antichar tchèque de 47 mm qui
avait à la fois une vitesse initiale
plus élevés et tire une mission plus
lourd que le pkk 36 allemand il emporté
86 au but la protection des trois
membres d'équipage étaient minimales la
super structure ouverte à l'arrière sur
le dessus ne comportait qu'un bouclier
d'une épaisseur de 14 mm 5 autour du
canon 202 exemplaires furent converti
jusqu'en février 41 par daimler benz et
skoda la plupart sont employées en 1941
en russie un petit nombre des penseurs
vigueur un servir en afrique du nord
trois compagnies l'unité 605 surveillée
en libye début 41 et participé aux
batailles majeures dans le désert
occidental jusqu'à el alamein
à la fin 1940 le même cas nom fut
commandée pour être montées sur les
chars renault r30 saint prix au français
en remplacement du ponceau 1
ces engins furent principalement
utilisés en normandie
les penseurs jaeger ab survivants
retirés du service en 1943 terminèrent
leur carrière dans les centres
d'entraînement
c'est une autre arme étrangères qui elle
est montée sur le nouveau penseriez
guerre les allemands ayant pris aux
russes un grand nombre de l'excellent
canon de 76 mm en 1941 la rencontre avec
les nouveaux chars soviétiques au début
de la campagne de russie fut un choc
pour l'armée allemande le renseignement
n'avait donné aucune information sur
l'existence des caves et un ec avait
deux seules les compétences militaires
des allemands compenser leur infériorité
technologique face à ces nouvelles
machines
ce fut le thé 34 qui créa la plus grande
surprise tant ils représentaient un bond
en avant dans la conception des chars
dans l'infanterie allemande obligé de
faire face à ses formidables engins
l'inefficacité du canon p aka 36 37 mm
déjà constaté lors de la bataille de
france fut largement confirmé en russie
même tiré à bout portant la munition
perforantes de ce canon antichar
rebondissait contre l'épée blindage de
ces monstres d'acier
le pkk 38 de 50 mm mis en service en
faible nombre juste avant barbare au
sein de figuères mieux cette arme ne
réussissais à pénétrer le blindage d'été
34 cas une faible distance
les allemands se tourne alors vers les
canons m 19 36 cm 19 39 de 76 mm
capturer un quantité depuis juin 41
chambres et pour pouvoir t-il à la
munition du pkk 42 75 mm qui fut mise en
service dans la précipitation avant la
fin de l'année 1941 et rebaptisé p aka
36 39
ces tubes allait servir l'armée
allemande jusqu'à la fin de la guerre le
prototype du pain servier gars 38 t
apparus dès décembre 41
par ailleurs le besoin d'un canon
automoteur capable de tenir tête chars
russes étaient grandissant le pkk 36,39
était une arme antichar redoutable bien
que la production du fragile pançard 38
tpri 142 le châssis fut produit pour
servir de plate-forme de canons anti
chars et d'artillerie jusqu'en 45
la disponibilité des variantes penseurs
2 d et e à la fin 41 provoque à leur
conversion pour l'emport du canon de 76
mm de manière inattendue les premiers
penseurs jaeger 38 est connue sous le
nom de mme harder 3 ne connurent pas
leur baptême du sang russie mais avec
l'afrika korps et bien qu'il opérera du
désert au stade de russie ce nouveau
véhicule n'était en fait à l'origine
qu'un bouche trou car les troupes en
avait désespérément besoin
le canot été capable de perforer 55 mm
de blindage jusqu'à 2000 mètres
mais le marder été handicapé par sa
silhouette massive alors qu'en russie
les équipages pouvaient tenter de
masquer leurs engins en attendant
l'ennemi immobile jusqu'au moment de
tirer appliquer une telle tactique dans
le désert était bien plus ardue la
protection balistique étant très faible
le bouclier n'est en effet que de 15 mm
ceux qui rendent l équipage très
vulnérables aux tirs directs de même qu
aux éclats d'obus exposants trop près du
véhicule
malgré tout trois cent soixante trois
exemplaires furent produits par l'usiné
bmm de prague la conversion grossière
des penseurs 2d en marder deux
témoignent de l'impatience avec laquelle
les 200 exemplaires produits entre avril
juin 42 étaient attendus au front
le penseur jaeger 2d apparu pour la
première fois aux informations
lorsqu'en juillet 42 le bataillon de
chasseurs de chars de la première ss
panzer division nadj standaard
adolf hitler reconstituer reposer parada
dans paris sur les champs elysées avec
d'autres détachement de l'unité
tous étaient peints de la livre et
standards gris sombre l'homme qui salue
n'est autre que le maréchal gerd von
rundstedt chef du groupement ouest
la majorité des 150 machines produites
jusqu'en mai 42 surtout engagé sur le
front de l'est au sein des pensées et
penseur grenadiers division qui mené
l'offensive dans le sud de la russie
même si le canon 76 mm donné toute
satisfaction
le marder de soufre et comme le
maraudeur troy de son imposante
silhouette la démonstration de la
puissance de feu du panshir jaeger 2d
fut faite au maréchal goering lorsqu'il
rendit visite à l'unité d'entraînement
des bataillons de chasseurs des chars de
la division portant son nom en un vil 43
deux mois plus tard plus de dix mille
soldats allaient se rendre
lorsque la tête de pont de l'accent
tunisie tomba sous les coups des alliés
le développement du pea cac40 de 75 mm
avaient été ralenties
malgré les contrats signés des 39 pour
un nouveau canon antichar l'apparition
de nouveaux blindés soviétiques à cheval
autosuffisance qui avait prévalu jusqu'à
l'heure un programme accéléré de raï
mittal bord si je lance à la production
et la mise en service des premiers pays
à cac 40 à la fin 1941 le pea cac 40
était d'une arme excellente son profil
bas permettez à son équipage de tirer
pleinement parti de la puissance de
pénétration et de la portée de sa
munition perforantes
il pouvait traverser 100 mm de blindage
sous un angle de 30 degrés à une
distance de 500 mètres la cadence de tir
normal était de 12 coups par minute mais
un équipage expérimenté pouvait faire
encore mieux
l'efficacité indéfectible du pea cac 40
ans fils de canons antichars standard
ainsi qu'une pièce d'artillerie légère
utilisé jusqu'à la fin de la guerre il
fut aussi utilisé sur de nombreux
châssis comme canon automoteur
en juin 40 de phares moman et daimler
benz reçurent l'ordre de réserve et 75 %
de leur production de châssis de panzers
2 à la construction d'un nouveau plan de
rigueur armé d'un canon antichar de 75
mm ce véhicule dénommé marder 2 du
produit jusqu'en juin 1943 lorsque
décision fut prise de consacrer toute la
production des châssis de peinture 2
halo buziet automoteurs léger vaise peu
jusqu alors 651 marder deux avaient été
produits employant aussi bien des
châssis neuf que ceux des premiers
modèles de poseurs de rentrer en
allemagne le marder 2 était en
configuration ouverte avec un blindage
légers montés sur le devant et les côtés
de la casemate du canon
alors qu'ils équipait les bataillons de
panzers rigueur beaucoup de marder deux
furent tout aussi utilisée par les
troupes aéroportées qui après les
lourdes pertes subies en crète furent
employées comme un vent très classique
sur l'ordre d'hitler
bien qu il servir sur tous les fronts
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre c'est lors
de la campagne de russie que le gros de
ces engins faire payer un lourd tribut
aux blindés soviétiques
l'arrivée du pea cac40 permis aux
équipages d'éliminer la plupart des
chars russes qu'ils engageaient avec
l'arrivée de l'hiver
livrée blanche suite appliqué pour aider
au camouflage lors des déplacements dans
les grandes étendues de la step de
concert avec le marqueur de au sein du
corps blindée ss en février et mars 1943
cervelle et mme harder 3 basée sur le
châssis du panzer 38 t avec un canopée à
42 75 mm qui sortir des chaînes de
montage de bmm à prague en octobre 42
remplaçant le canon ruche présent
d'origine sur le maraudeur troy
le nouveau modèle était doté d'un
compartiment de tir surbaissé abritant
un pea cac 40 dont 417 exemplaires sur
produits les marder 3 de l'alep
standaard
adolf hitler combattaient dans les
faubourgs de la ville de karkhov le
théâtre d'une bataille décisive opposant
les chars de la waffen ss aux troupes
soviétiques du front burnett début 1943
le mar 2-3 participa à de violents
combats durant toute l'année 43
comme on peut le voir ici avec ce
bataillon de panzers rigueur de la
troisième ss panzer division tatane cov
lors de la bataille de koursk en juillet
les marder trois furent également
employé de manière intensive au sein des
divisions de l'armée de terre et de la
luftwaffe de la russie à l'italie
l'opération axe préparée de longue date
par les allemands pour l'occupation
l'italie se déroulant en septembre 43
les forces se déplaçant à travers les
montagnes jusqu'en italie septentrionale
et est doté des derniers marder 3 ce
nouveau modèle était le résultat d'une
révision majeure du concept basé sur le
châssis du panzer 38 et dont le moteur
était recentrer et le compartiment de
tir du pea cac40 déplacé à l'arrière
près de 1000 exemplaires furent
fabriqués par bm m les canons
automoteurs sur employés en largement
plus grand nombre que les chars par les
allemands sur le théâtre italien
le terrain montagneux étant bien plus
propice à leur utilisation
ce que démontre largement ces images de
mares dirt3 de fans production opérant
dans la région de monte cassino au
premier semestre 44 utilisant les ruines
d'un village bombardé le marder
progresse à découvert à la proche de
nouvelles cibles
conscient de la capacité des pilotes à
détecter les traces des chars depuis le
ciel
celles ci sont balayés par l'un des
soldats le marder rejoint une position
de tir en bordure du village lui ouvrant
un superbe angle de tir sur la vallée en
contrebas une fois l'ennemi repérer le
tireur charge d'un obus perforant panzer
granat 40
après quelques tirs le marder se retire
pour éviter que la position soit
pilonnée par l'artillerie adverse où
l'aviation les modèles tardive de mme
harder trois furent largement utilisés
lors de la retraite de landi à partir du
6 juin
comme pour tous les véhicules allemands
présents sur le théâtre un camouflage
efficace et des primordial afin
d'échapper aux chasseurs bombardiers
alliés
les allemands utilisèrent beaucoup de
chars français capturés comme base pour
leurs canons automoteurs alors qu'une
certaine quantité de fcm et de haute ce
qui fut remonté avec canon pea cac 40
le plus grand nombre furent montés sur
des chenilles est lorraine une bonne
quantité de ces machines fiable était
tombée aux mains des allemands en 1941
42 et au moment où ceux-ci avaient
désespérément besoin de motoriser autant
de canons antichars que possible
décision fut prise de convertir 170 ch
ni est lorraine afin d'y monter le pea
cac 40
une partie fut envoyé en russie et en
italie tandis que le gros de l'effectif
reste à en france au service des troupes
d'occupation
les images du lauren cheney peur sont
rares et celles ci le montre en
normandie en 1944
seules quelques-unes de ces machines
survécurent à la destruction des forces
allemandes lors de cette campagne
parmi tous les châssis de chars français
converti le hotchkiss h 39 fut le plus
grandement modifié il fut quasiment
désossé furent construits pour y monter
le pea cac 40 seules 24 exemplaires
furent ainsi transformer tous sont
servis en france le dernier châssis
adopter pour monter le pea cac 40
n'était qu'un expédient désespéré qui
reflétait bien l'état de précarité
matérielle dont souffre l armée
allemande à la fin 44 dans l'espoir de
placer autant de canons antichars que
possible sur des châssis automoteur
hitler ordonna que le semis chenilles et
sdk et faisait 251 des fûts modifié pour
accueillir le pea cac40 toute larme
excepté ses roues pouvait prendre place
dans le havre traque au prix de
modifications mineures mises en oeuvre
par un équipage de quatre hommes
ils pouvaient emporter 22 obus de 75 mm
néanmoins le canon surchargé l'engin et
le sdk est faisait 251 22 étaient en
réel surpoids
l'un des premiers exerce sortie des
chaînes de production fut présenté à
hitler à l'occasion de son anniversaire
le 20 avril 44
cette nouvelle variante du promeneur 38
et marqua un vrai progrès par rapport
aux chasseurs de chars conventionnelle
et leur compartiment ouvert qui rendent
l équipage très vulnérable le razer fut
dessiné sur le modèle des chasseurs de
chars doté d'une superstructure
enveloppante et protégés c'est pour
cette raison que le header fut ranger
dans la catégorie des yaks panzer et non
des panzers jager la production du
head's up débutants aux usines skoda et
b même en mai 44 celle du maraudeur troy
aikman arrêté
l'armement première estelle canon de 75
mm tandis que le compartiment ferme et
offrait à équipage une bien meilleure
protection que les chasseurs de chars
précédent celui ci se trouvait également
dans un espace plus confiné rendant la
manoeuvre assez difficile cela empêchait
les mouvements du canon qui ne pouvait
en conséquence faire feu que sur un
chantier réduit malgré ses limitations
le razer devint l'un des engins les plus
efficaces et là des plus fréquemment
rencontrées au sein l'armée allemande
durant la dernière année de la guerre
l'emploi efficace des calmants d'assaut
dans le rôle de tueur de charme n'a au
développement d'un canon capable de
remplir les deux missions construit
autour d'une superstructure blindés
montés sur le châssis d'affonter 4le
yade panzer quatre armés d'un canon l 48
de 75 mm entre en production chez bomag
en janvier 44 il servir avec la 116e
penseurs division' en normandie en août
le yak panzer quatre furets armée avec
le canon elle 70 de 75 mm que l'on
retrouve sur le char panthères comme le
poids du tube peser sur l'avant du
châssis
les deux premiers galets de roulement à
bandage en caoutchouc furent remplacées
par des galets en acier parallèlement
aux vendeurs 4,70 construit par vos mac
une variante était produite par
nibelungen werc en autriche
le corps du yak panzer 4 fut modifié est
monté directement sur laquelle 1.4
standard ce qui mena aux poseurs 4,70 ça
que l'on peut distinguer du modèle
fabriqué par baumann grâce à ses côtés
verticaux
le plus gros le plus lourd et le plus
puissant canon antichar jamais entrer en
service au sein de la wehrmacht fut le
pkk 43 de 90 mm cette arme donné à la
munition au tungstène une vitesse
initiale de 1130 mètres par seconde qui
lui permettait de percevoir un thé 34 à
3500 mètres basé sur le même châssis
dérivé des panzers 3 et 4 et partageant
la même super structure avec le canon
automoteur humble le nash horn armée du
canon paix à 43 2 88 mm connu son
baptême du feu lors de l'opération
citadelle en juillet 43
bien qu'il fût similaire en apparence
aux penseurs jaeger improvisé vu
précédemment le nashor nhs était
totalement conçu autour du canon p aka
contrairement aux autres penseurs
vigueur plus petit il ne fut pas
distribués au bataillon de chasseurs de
chats mais fut affecté à des sections
spéciales au niveau du corps d'armée et
détaché selon les besoins opérationnels
la plupart des 494 exemplaires
construits servir en russie mais furent
également vu en italie à la fin de la
guerre
le canon standard employés par l'armée
allemande au niveau de la division
depuis son introduction en 1935 jusqu'à
la fin du conflit et l es h 18 de 105 mm
cette pièce a connu tous les fronts les
vastes plaines gelées de la finlande au
désert brûlant d'afrique du nord
arm multi usages et largement employé le
f h18 était monté sur un attelage en
deux parties et pour les premiers
modèles de larges roues d'acier dotée de
pneus en caoutchouc sur les variantes
ultérieure elle fut remplacée par des
roues à rayons un obus de 14 kg 8
pouvait atteindre une cible jusqu'à une
distance de 2500 m l'expérience acquise
en l'est où le poids du canon cousin
nombre d'embourbement incite à
développer un attelage plus léger dérivé
du pea cac 40
alors que les semis chauny sdk f 7 251 4
et sdk et cède 3,2 tonnes et est utilisé
pour tracter le canon de 105 mm en
afrique du nord et en russie
le gros de ceux engagés en europe et
dans l'est étaient tirées par des
chevaux en 1939 un frein de bouche suit
ajouté afin d'augmenter la portée du
canon
conçu en 1942 dans le but de conférer
une plus grande mobilité aux canons de
105 mm affectés aux formations mobile
le canon automoteur vaste peu et est
basé sur un penseur de largement modifié
bien qu'il fut conçu par alc est la
production fut assurée par fars mots en
février 43 la décision fut prise de
diriger toute la production de châssis
de penseurs 2 chez le constructeur du ve
est le nouveau canon automoteur eu son
baptême du feu lors de l'opération
citadelle l'offensive sur course qu'en
juillet 43
les engins vu ici en actions
appartiennent de détachement
d'artillerie automotrices de la 3e et
ses sponsors dionnet division tout une
clope à partir de mi 43 les vestes peu
commencèrent à apparaître en nombre
croissant parmi les unités d'artillerie
autopropulsés des divisions des penseurs
grenadiers l'équipement des unités sur
le front de l'est étaient prioritaires
car le besoin d'une artillerie mobile
devenait de plus en plus pressants il
s'agissait d'appuyer de faire mouvement
décrit chars qui devaient se déplacer
d'une position à une autre
au fil des contre attaques soviétique
la possibilité pour les formations de
penseurs de déployer leurs crocs partir
immobile leur permettait de maximiser
leur manière limitée en lançant des
contres attaques face une armée rouge
toujours plus imposante déployés le long
de la ligne de fond les vestes peu
devait effectuer des tirs de barrage
très concentré avant les attaques
puis accompagné les blindés alors qu'ils
avançaient des formations de combat
adapté et comprenant 10 heures type
d'armement dont les vestes peu s'est
rapidement mise en place par les
allemands pour faire face aux percées
ennemis à la fin d'été 44 comme on peut
le constater sur ces images
la contre attaque locale est lancée par
les forces et allemande appuyée par des
choucas en biélorussie occidental le
commandant supervisant l'opération
alléger la luftwaffe robert ritter en
prime
après le bombardement aérien
préliminaire l'infanterie allemande si
mouvement pour rechercher le contact de
l'ennemi d'armement employés au sein du
cab regroupe inclut des charpentes air
des marcs d'or 3 des transports de
troupe de l'artillerie anti-aérienne
mobile des canons antiaériens de 88 mm
tracter ainsi qu'un soutien d'artillerie
fournie par un petit détachement de
vespa l'apparition d'une formation
aérienne soviétique constitué
d'iliouchine 2 sturmovik déclencha les
tirs des canons de 90 mm les avions
soviétiques cible les penseurs en
mouvement à travers la plaine
un certain nombre sont touchés et abattu
alors que les canons de 37 millimètres
se joignent à la dcn
le détachement de vastes place c'est
cannes en position de tir pour pilonner
l'ennemi avant que l'infanterie ne donne
l'assaut
et canons automoteurs entier à rien flac
vierling de 20 mm se joignent maintenant
la bataille aérienne alors que les îles
ue-chine de soviétiques poursuivre leurs
attaques
les troupes allemandes au sol son
mouvement sous le feu des avions russes
tandis que les canons de la flac
continue de tirer pour maintenir une
ombrelle protectrice au dessus des
troupes au sol
un store modique touché par la dca
allemande plongèrent le sol
bien que les bombes des avions russes
continuent de tomber l'infanterie
allemande poursuit son avancée
les blessés sont rapatriés vers
l'arrière et la bataille continue sous
les bombardements soviétique
bombardements et pilonnages d'artillerie
réduisent l'horizon un mur d'explosion
dans cette dernière séquence l'étude de
88 mm de l'adc à fond une autre victime
un chasseur russe qui plongèrent le sol
dans un nuage de fumée
bien que le vch peu été généralement
bien accueillie par ses utilisateurs
il n'était pas exempt de défauts le
châssis du panther 2 était prévu pour un
petit véhicule et le compartiment situé
à l'arrière de la machine était trop
consignes et par un équipage de quatre
hommes de même que les autres canons à
tous au vert il ne serait qu'une
protection réduite et avait une
silhouette massive
toutefois les 676 exemple un produit
auquel s'ajoutent les 159 transporteurs
de munitions qui furent utilisés pour
transporter les obus de 105 mm sur des
feuilles avec succès jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre illfurth engagé non seulement
sur le front de l'est mais aussi en
europe occidentale face aux alliés à
partir de juin 44
nous avons déjà évoqué l'utilisation
intensive par les allemands de charpiot
français est transformé en canon
automoteur l'un des plus films et reste
celui employant le châssis licha
religieux hotchkiss sur lequel étaient
montés l'obusier de 105 mm
48 de ses canons automoteurs sur produit
est utilisé dans des unités servant
france en 1942 chacun connu des combats
intenses avec le 8e bataillon
d'artillerie blindé lors de la campagne
de normandie il servir de concert avec
les chenillettes lorraine également
modifié pour recevoir le canon ef h 18
de 105 mm seuls 24 de ces derniers sur
produits
comme pour tous les véhicules allemands
servent en normandie les préalables à
survie inclus et la capacité opéré
depuis un couvert même si le schéma de
camouflage distinctifs avec un fond
sable et de grosses taches des rôles il
était efficace
il était nécessaire de profiter des
arbres et des de la campagne normande
pour se soustraire au vu des chasseurs
bombardiers alliés constamment présents
dans le ciel une fois en place le groupe
prépare et les munitions et commencé le
tir c'est automoteurs embarqué trente
deux obus à peu près autant que les
vagues peuvent ils sont venus ici en
opération avec un détachement
d'automoteurs loup humble en provenance
d'une division de chars de la waffen ss
entré en service en 1933 le site 33
équipes allaient peloton d'artillerie
lourde des régiments d'infanterie est
resté en service jusqu'en 45 avec une
portée maximale de seulement 4700 m sa
tâche consistait à effectuer des tirs de
destruction sur les positions ennemies
au moment où l'incendié allemands entrés
en action sa munition relativement
lourde peser 38 kg et le canot avait une
cadence de tir de deux à trois coups par
minute
c'est cet arbre qui fut monté sur le
premier automoteurs d'artillerie
développé pour la wehrmacht
la décision de monter le sic 33 sur un
châssis automoteur mena l'utilisation du
pense un b le montage suis conçu par al
qaîda berlin qui convertit 38 pensant un
début février 40
ils entonnent en service pour la
campagne de france
le véhicule issu de ces développements
peser quelques 3 tonnes de plus que le
penseur ab standard le canon de 105 mm
et est monté dans un grand compartiment
au dessus de l'habitacle et lui donner
une apparence très cubique
il démarra les combats au sein de six
compagnies d'infanterie lourdes chacune
rattacher un penseur division en mai 40
laissait l'image de ce véhicule en
action le montre en train de détruire
des positions défensives alors que
l'infanterie pénètre dans une ville
française en général le véhicule se
révéler efficace dans l'action et fut
[__] employés dans les balkans et en
russie pour finalement disparaître du
champ de bataille fin 43 lorsque les
survivants servir avec la 5ème penseurs
division sur le front de l'est
aucun autre ne fut construit car le
canon était trop lourd pour le châssis
est une si haute silhouette n'était pas
souhaitée en 1941 à une tentative de
monter le sig 33 sur un châssis de
penseurs de et choix et seuls 12
exemplaires furent construits néanmoins
le sic 33 montées sur le penseur 1b
constitua par l'armée allemande une
expérience enrichissante
concernant l'utilisation de l'artillerie
automotrices
la plateforme ayant accueilli le sig 33
ans plus grand nombre fait le penseur 38
et les deux modèles produits fut
rebaptisé bisons le premier paru en
février 43 il utilisait le châssis d'un
char avec le canon monté à l'avant dans
une superstructure carré alors que ces
armes étaient attendus pour la campagne
d'été à venir
les 90 premiers exemplaires du modèle vu
ici sur converties sur la base du
penseur 38 et modèles h
de retour du front est ensuite affecté
aux compagnies d'artillerie lourde des
divisions des penseurs grenadiers
le bison entrée en service en 43 et fut
engagé en tunisie en france et en russie
l'exemplaire vu ici appartenu au fun et
16 déployée lors de la bataille de
koursk en juillet
un petit nombre d'entre eux combattirent
également en normandie en 44 vue sur ces
images prises à milan en août 43 où il
fut envoyé pour une mission de sécurité
après avoir été malmené à koursk ce pays
et 38 et bisons rarement filmer à partir
la première ss panzer division life
stand à adolf hitler
il dépasse ici un marder 3 de dernière
génération appartenant au bataillon de
penseurs rigueur de la division 282
exemplaires de la version finale du
bison furent équipés du ciq 33 montées
sur le même châssis du pcet 38 est
utilisé pour les derniers marder trois
modèles tardy le sic 33 s'est également
payé en 1941 pour fabriquer un canon
d'assaut entièrement blindés puissant
sur châssis de penseurs 3 e et f 8 la
production de séries ne puis jamais
lancée et seuls 24 exemplaires sortir
des usines
il servira à stalingrad en 1942 et leurs
survivants participèrent à la percée de
cool and en russie méridionale 64 ans
dassault brume baer sur leurs débuts au
sein du 216e bataillon de cas dont
dassault lors de la bataille de koursk
en juillet 43
conçu comme un engin blindé d'assaut
lourd cette machine avait les faveurs
dites leur qu'ils en avaient ordonné la
production de top 40 2 le sic 33 étaient
montés sur une rotule dans une cabine
lourdement blindé avec 100 mm de
blindage à l'avant et 50 mm sur les
côtés la première version manqué d'une
mitrailleuse tirant vers l'avant et de
plus l'épiscope du pilote était monté
trop bras sur l'avant la superstructure
le brombert de milieux production
pouvait se distinguer facilement par le
périscope monté sur le poste de pilotage
on aperçoit un bromberg de dernière
génération passant derrière cet équipage
que l'on décor pour sa bravoure lors de
rudes combats contre les britanniques à
la frontière hollandaise
la superstructure blindée du groupe bert
offrait une protection un espace
intérieur par un équipage de cinq hommes
nettement meilleur que le panzer 4 de
plus le dernier modèle de brume baer
avait été largement modifié afin
d'incorporer un nombre significatif
d'amélioration l'absence d'une
mitrailleuse d'autodéfense eu ainsi
comblé par le montage d'une rotule sur
le côté gauche du glacis avant le
blindage de ce dernier fit également
amélioré le calibre standard des canons
lourds de l'artillerie allemande durant
la guerre était de 150 mm ces armes
surtemps pays dans un certain nombre de
versions différentes
là où le gros de l'artillerie lourde
était tirée par des chevaux dfh 18 250
mm
rattaché aux puncheurs division des
quais tractées par des engins chaque
panzer division de disposer de trois
bataillons d'artillerie dont un
d'artillerie lourde à trois batteries de
quatre canons tractés par des semis
chenu et de huit hommes même si la
vitesse avec laquelle de se nicher
millet ou et amener les canons sur zone
était impressionnant comparé à la
lenteur des chevaux la mise en batterie
tous les pans d'une demi heure
les performances de larmes en elle-même
était néanmoins satisfaisante
la fh 18 pouvait tirer au but de 43 kg 5
à une distance de 13 km mais ce que les
unités voulais c'était un automoteur
chenille est doté du canons de 150 mm
qu'elle pourrait déployer à la demande
elle allait devoir attendre jusqu'en
le prototype du vieux hull était à l'eau
budget automoteurs armé d'un tube de 150
mm avec un gros frein de bouche
le tout monté sur un châssis de pointe
sur trois ou quatre il a paru en 1942
lorsque la décision fut prise de lancer
sa production
les emf connurent leur baptême du feu en
juillet 43 durant l'opération citadelle
utilisé par le bataillon d'artillerie
lourde de la division ss totenkopf les
premiers e mails se reconnaissent au
compartiment du pilote qui ressort du
glacis avant incliné sur les dernières
versions ce compartiment fut élargie à
tout l'avant du véhicule
lorsqu'il n'est pas utilisé le canot de
150 mm est maintenu en place fixé aux
glacis
le hubble partage avec tous les autres
canons automoteurs allemand de cette
époque la super structure à toit ouvert
et le faible adage
c'était moins problématique pour
l'équipage du fait qu'il fut vrai le feu
à une certaine distance des zones de
combat il n'était donc pas aussi
vulnérables que les équipages des
panzers jaeger la dotation initiale de
humer fut réduite à seulement six
exemplaires par division avec en plus un
certain nombre d'exemplaires de la
variante de ravitaillement en munitions
ces véhicules étaient nécessaires dans
la mesure où le hubble ne transportait
que 18e but de 150 mm à son bord très
souvent rapidement utiliser des
connaissances barrage commencer la
disponibilité du veulent donner aux
penseurs division' sa possibilité de
frapper durement les forces soviétiques
à l'instant où elle lançait une contre
offensive bien que leur humble et
toujours été vu comme une solution
temporaire en attendant le développement
d'un canon automoteur spécifique il ne
fut jamais disponibles en nombre
suffisant pour satisfaire la demande
opérationnel les ravens étaient souvent
employés de concert avec veste peu plus
petits comme on peut le voir sur ces
images prises en hongrie au début 1945
lorsque le dr goebbels choisi de rendre
une dernière visite eu le front de
l'oder en mars 1945 il fut conviée à
assister au tir d'un unique hubble ce
qui était peut-être symptomatique de la
décroissance de la puissance militaire
de l'allemagne
ce véhicule avait fait ses preuves et
lorsque la production ses 144 666 canon
et 150 véhicules pourvoyeur avait été
construit par halkett et deutsch jeunes
verts qui l'avait remarques étaient
entrés dans la seconde guerre mondiale
avec un arsenal exceptionnel de canons
anti-aériens léger très efficace qui
furent utilisées avec succès tout au
long du conflit
le cal hoflack 32 20 mm apparu dans les
années 1930 et il était déjà largement
répandu lorsque ce film sur la luftwaffe
fut diffusé par le ministère de l'air
des canons léger de chez croupe sont mis
en position de tir
l'inde et les est descendu son châssis
transport pour être mis en batterie
le soldat qui porte le télémètre donne
la distance alors que passe deux avions
au dessus de lui
le canon antiaérien rapidement tourné
sur son axe poursuivre les cibles que le
tireur doit engager
six ans plus tard la même procédure sera
suivie un peu partout ici
laflaque tirs sur les avions alliés au
dessus du détroit de messine là un
artilleur fait le guet depuis un flop
wehrling en russie un autre ouvre le feu
sur les avions alliés qui le survolent
en italie méridionale et y est imité par
un canon de flaques de 37 mm et parano
de 20 mm ces trois armes ont été
utilisées par la flak allemande jusqu'en
1945 de l'océan arctique jusqu'à la mer
egée et du golfe de gascogne à la mer
noire
le semis chenille et des mags d'une
tonne fut le premier véhicule à être
utilisé comme plate-forme pour canons
antiaériens initialement ce véhicule
était armé d'un tube flac 30 de 20 mm on
les dénomme as dkfz 10,4 mais il fut
d'ensuite supplanté par le flac 38 et
l'engin sdk fz6 5
bien que conçu pour la protection anti
aériennes des unités militaires
ces deux variantes fut utilisé pour la
[__] terrestre le canon de 20 mm et est
idéal pour engager des positions
fortifiées à l'aide de munitions
explosives ou perforantes
dans la première phase de la campagne
réussie on découvrit que la flaque
pouvait être utilisé pour pénétrer le
blindage de nombreux modèles de chars
russes dépassé technologiquement bien
que les munitions fut transporté dans
une petite pièce attachée sur les côtés
de la plateforme sur laquelle le canon
était monté la plupart des des macaques
tractait une remorque à deux roues
contenant des munitions supplémentaires
un total de sept hommes étaient
nécessaires pour conduire l'engin mettre
en batterie et exécuté le tir
le principal inconvénient ce modèle
était que l'équipage était totalement
explosion au feu ennemi
le souci d'assurer un minimum de
protection balistique aux occupants
n'ayant pas été pris en compte avant un
stade avancé de la production à savoir
l'installation d'un carénage blindés
pour le pilote et d'un bouclier pour le
canon hormis ces modifications le des
mac demeurent inchangées fut produit par
de nombreux constructeurs différents
jusqu'à l'arrêt de la production en 1944
610 exemplaires avaient été construits
il servit sur tous les fronts et fut de
toutes les batailles jusqu'à fin de la
guerre
laflaque panzer 38 et était un engin
conçu dans l'urgence
en attendant de lancer un sac panzer
plus sophistiqués
alors que la supériorité à rien de la
luftwaffe disparaissaient aussi bien à
l'est qu'à l'ouest
l'armée avait besoin de tous les moyens
de défense antiaérienne disponibles
l'avers marque avec une propension armés
tous les châssis qui pouvait l'être
des camions standards tels que le opel
bleach et le transport de troupes rohr
ch furent modifiées afin de transporter
des tubes de 20 mm la plupart du temps
utilisé pour la plus terrestre
la polyvalence du semis chenilles et de
8 tonnes le krauss maffei eu pour
résultat que 319 d'entre eux furent tarn
et du flac vierling de 20 mm sa
production se poursuivant jusqu'en 1944
pour accueillir larmes tous les sièges
et layrac de stockage de munitions du
tracteur d'artillerie fut retirée et
remplacée par une plateforme à ridelles
le flac vierling était monté sur la
plateforme dix hommes étaient
nécessaires pour conduire et servir
larmes
les munitions étaient généralement
transportés dans une remorque la
nécessité d'une protection minimum pour
le pilote fut reconnu en 43 et un
carénage blindés installer un exemplaire
de cette version tardive est visible ici
à budapest début 44
l'une des plus belles séquences montrant
un familier de 8 tonnes et un flag
wehrling en action fut prise lors de
l'opération market garden
la tentative avortée des alliés de
reprendre les ponts sur le rhin à arnhem
en septembre 44
le caméraman a filmé un sac werning
cesse en train de tirer chez les
parachutistes britanniques en descente
et sur les avions qui les avait largué
les vols de ravitaillement ultérieure
assurée par des sterling paient un lourd
tribut à la flaque allemande parce qu'il
devait voler relativement bas au dessus
des zones de largage
beaucoup furent abattus les camions
blindés servira également de plateforme
aux flaques vierling ces images en
italie en 1944 en témoigne
sur les 3000 familles chenilles et 2,5
tonnes construit quelques 339 furent
utilisés pour y monter le canon
antiaérien flag 36 de 37 mm comme sur
tous les semis chauny est modifié pour
servir à l'adc à la partie transport de
troupes fut remplacé par un plateau et
des ridelles les munitions étaient
transportés dans une remorque larmes
étaient utilisés pour la défense
antiaérienne et pour l'appui terrestre
la plupart furent déployés sur le front
de l'est
ces semis chenilles et 2,5 tonnes
servent avec les bataillons aérien de la
deuxième ss panzer grenat dire des
visions lors de la vence du corps
blindée ss au cours de l'offensive de
course en juillet 43
le smi sli ubs dkfz 7 de 8 tonnes fut
adapté au transport du canon flac 36 de
37 millimètres en 1943 lorsque la
production du semis chenier 2,5 tonnes
fut arrêté l'ajout du canon porta le
poids du véhicule
aaron stone 5 les munitions pour le
canon de décès a été transporté dans une
remorque thunder hanniger 57
spécialement conçu pour transporter des
obus de 37 mm le flac 36 étaient à canon
puissants souvent utilisé en tire direct
la plupart des semis chenilles et vu
dans cette séquence appartiennent à la
waffen ss et en particulier aux flaques
aptel lung de l'alep standaard
adolf hitler sur ces images une des
dernières machines de ce type aient vu
ici à rome avec un carénage blindés ici
à l'open maul tir camoufler transportant
à canaules 37 mm en mouvement le long
d'une route de normandie
aux actualités cinématographiques de mai
43 on pouvait voir un exercice terrestre
de la luftwaffe en russie impliquant une
unité complète de défense antiaérienne
l'intérêt réside dans la diversité des
équipements employés en dehors du des
mags armé d'un canon de 20 mm et il y
avait également un grand nombre de
camions en 4 4 mercedes benz de 4 tonnes
et demie
le premier ce détachement de canon de 88
mm semble n'avoir aucune difficulté
employés son cube aussi bien appuyé
terrestre quand armes antichars le
collège hors zone loot de la 21e panzer
division se rappelle comment en
normandie
il menace a dû tirer sur un officier de
la sixième division de la luftwaffe
car celui ci ne voulait pas utiliser ces
canons de 88 contre des chars lors de
l'opération goodwood
l'intérieur de laquelle ces images ont
été tournées significative le front de
l'est connaissaient sa plus longue
accalmie de toute la guerre alors que
les soviétiques se repliaient
délibérément pour se préparer à
l'inévitable offensive d'été dirigée
contre le saillant de koursk la période
précédant le 5 juillet date à laquelle
l'opération citadelle était finalement
lancé fut marquée de l'un des
entraînements les plus rigoureux conduit
par l'armée allemande sur le front de
l'est
on suppose que cette unité attend de
prendre part à l'opération
bien que la supériorité aérienne de la
luftwaffe ne fut plus garanti en russie
l'armée de l'air soviétique n'avait pas
encore pris le contrôle des cieux dans
ces circonstances les unités de flaques
de la luftwaffe était plus à même
d'engager des sharks des avions mais
cette situation allait bientôt changer
les attaques aériennes soviétique contre
les formations terrestre allemande et
leur lignes logistiques n'eurent jamais
l'échelle le degré de sophistication
atteint par les alliés en europe
occidentale
néanmoins la perte du contrôle d air
dans l'est rendent ils avaient remarque
bien plus vulnérable au cours de cette
période d assaut aérien soviétique
augmentèrent alors que les défenses
allemandes s'appuyer sur des unités
antiaériennes mobile la demande en
véhicules de des syrahs capable de faire
face à la menace s'intensifia à l'ouest
la domination aérienne alliée est
écrasante
à partir du débarquement une vague
d'opérations aériennes sans précédent v
les chasseurs bombardiers alliés évolue
au dessus de la france et des pays bas
mitraillant sans relâche tout mouvement
d'unités allemandes sur cet exemple
typique les p 38 lightning et les p 47
cents d'un bol de l'us army air force
volts en rase motte pour frapper des
positions allemandes en l'absence totale
de la luftwaffe la wehrmacht ne pouvait
compter que sur la flac pour se protéger
mais il fallait toujours plus et la
flaque avait besoin d'engins mobiles
entièrement chenilles et il devenait
également très clair que beaucoup
d'avions alliés et est maintenant bien
protégés contre les munitions de 20 mm
utilisé jusqu alors par la flak le plus
lourd qu'à limoges / demandé est le 37
mm devant alors le standard qui pourra
battre en plus grand nombre les
appareils de la force aérienne alliée de
ses doléances émerger une nouvelle
génération de flacq penseurs certains
athées des solutions provisoires choisi
en attendant le développement du modèle
plus puissant et sophistiqué des
exemples tels que le google blitz et le
panthères co eliane employeur un calibre
plus lourd
il y avait une cadence de tir nettement
plus élevé mais aucun entrer en service
avant la capitulation du reich en mai 45
le verbe vinh apparu à la fin 43 en tant
que chars anti aériens basée sur le
châssis du panzer 4 une tourelle
spécifique protégé par 16 mm de blindage
avait été prévu afin que l'équipage
puisse servir le flac ferling de 20 mm
tout en étant protégé
les urnes gyms opérèrent près de la
frontière allemande dans la région de m
à la fin 44 tirant sur des bombardiers
américains
une rafale de 20 mm tirée par des airs
melvin vient d'abattre un bombardier
américain b 26 seulement 86 vince sûrs
produit jusqu'en novembre 44
à cette date il fut décidé que le
khalife de 20 mm n'étaient plus adaptés
à la lutte anti aérienne et que
poursuivre la production d'armes de ce
calibre était un gâchis de ressources
le remplaçant du vbl wendt fut losc
vinke qui utilisait un tube de 37 mm
flac 43 dans une tourelle similaire
monté sur un châssis de par hasard
quatre le flac 43 étaient également
payer sur une autre conversation du
panzer 4 avec une super structure à 4
ridel qui pouvait être déplié pour le
tir
il est thématisé möbel wagen camions de
meubles dans des raisons évidentes 242 6
engins fer produit jusqu'en mars 45
lorsque kevin et le mobile vague devait
être remplacé par le coup gueule blitz
dans naturel était armé de deux canons
de 30 mm à haute cadence de tir mais la
guerre s'acheva avant qu'il n'ait pu
être fabriquée en grand nombre entré en
service dans les derniers mois du
conflit le drilling était un semis
chénier anti aériens basée sur les sdk
et 7,25 des armées de 3 40 15 minutes
issu de vieux stocks de la luftwaffe est
monté sur un affût pc à l'intérieur du
compartiment d'un semis chénier
les trois canons pouvait cracher jusqu'à
2100 coups à la minute
ceux observés ici sont sur le fond de
l'eau d'heure en mars 45 lorsque la
guerre éclate en 1939 le canon de 88 mm
dans ses différentes versions à savoir
les flaques 18 36 et 37 constituer
l'épiné dorsale défense antiaérienne de
l'allemagne sur son sol et de la
wehrmacht à l'étranger dans son rôle
initial de canons anti-aériens le 88 mm
pouvaient tirer jusqu'à 15 bus pesant
chacun 9 kg toutes les minutes
ce qui est démontré ici par un équipage
de la waffen ss savent en russie à la
fin d'été 41 le suivi précis de l'avion
et l'utilisation de télé m permettent à
l'artilleur de placer ses coups très
précis près de l'avion et demi dans
cette séquence il utilise également le
flac 32 20 mm de concert avec le 80 mm
les vues touche un bombardier russe
certainement un tu paul ffp2 qui plonge
et se désintègrent durant son pic et
finale
un autre détachement de canon de 88 mm
utilisé en défense antiaérienne cette
fois servi par les équipes anti
aériennes de la luftwaffe engage un
avion soviétique en 41 un nombre
important de victoires terrestres sont
bien repérable sur l'étude de 88 mm ces
soldats de la luftwaffe ont donc déjà
expérimenté le combat anti char en 1941
l'armée lancé un programme pour monter
le canon de 80 mm sur un châssis chénier
le résultat fut le sens de fargues est
elle apparue faire 42 avec un canon flac
37 de 81 mm en 1944 le même celle ci fut
utilisé pour monter le flac 41 de 88 mm
plus puissant encore une fois le concept
ne fut pas suivie une production le flac
41 fut conçu par hi métal bord sic est
rarement filmé à part celui ci dans le
rôle de canons antichars en mars 45
produit en secret afin d'éviter de
tomber sous le coup du traité de
versailles
le mortier multitubes levé rendent de
grands services à la wehrmacht durant la
seconde guerre mondiale elle réalisable
dès sa première utilisation l'impact
psychologique de cette arme
le 1 que sa puissance destructrice
le premier modèle qui entrait en service
en 41 fut le vert fort de 150 minutes à
six tubes monté sur un châssis de paix à
4,38 qui pouvaient effectuer à tirs
multiples toutes les deux secondes
introduit en 1942 les lance-roquettes de
280 300 mm plus lourd et plus gros
pouvait également tirer si munitions
d'un coup mais depuis un châssis à roues
plus lourd à toit ouvert le plus gros
lance roquette à paris en 1941 et
utiliser un lanceur monté sur le sol est
relevé pour le tir
c'est vers feurs de 320 me matas tête
incendiaire qui est utilisé pour
montbard dievart se vit lors du
soulèvement de la ville
l'importance de césar pour la wehrmacht
peut se mesure à l'augmentation des
servants de verseur qui passèrent de
2000 fichier solde en 39 à 135 milles en
une telle expansion reflète l'efficacité
de ces armes
une batterie de six lanceurs de 150 mm
pouvaient envoyer dans le ciel une salle
de trente six roquettes en 10 secondes
avec une deuxième suivant une minute
d'intervalle alors que la guerre
progresser les vers se regrouper en
grand nombre une brigade mixte de 384
lanceur de 150 mm et de 325 anciens de
210 mm pouvait saturé une zone avec six
tonnes de munitions cinq secondes en
répétant la manoeuvre une minute plus
tard
l'artillerie conventionnelle nécessité
80 une batterie pour obtenir le même
effet l'impact explosif de ces armes
s'accompagner de laisser psychologique
mais les verseur n'était pas sans
limites non plus leur utilisation si
près de la ligne de front à tirer leçon
et demi et les pertes parmi leurs
servants était élevé les batteries de
vaccins étaient vulnérables avant et
après le tir
ces images prises en normandie montre
comment une batterie après avoir été
tracté sur sa position par les semis
chenilles et prend un certain temps
avant d'être en mesure de tirer une fois
le tir effectué les flammes et la fumée
les sépare les roquettes
marc la position pour les yeux perçants
des observateurs avancent ennemis en
normandie les tirs de contre batterie
était très rapide
souvent les équipages devaient refaire
sur fauchées par des tirs de contre
batterie alors qu'il reconditionnés
leurs armes pour faire mouvement sur une
nouvelle position même si l'effet de ces
nouvelles armes et qui est indéniable la
wehrmacht reconnu que pour accroître
leur efficacité
elle devait rendre plus mobile ces
unités de verseur
la solution vint en 1943 avec l'ordre
donné au peuple de modifier son véhicule
semi chenier pour pouvoir y ajouter une
structure blindés le camion blindé semi
chénier produit par open en réponse à la
demande de l'armée allemande
utiliser le châssis de leurs véhicules
de transport standards mahul tir sur
lequel il avait ajouté un blindage le
lance roquettes les spécialement conçu
pour accueillir dix tubes et les
munitions embarqué permettait un engin
2-2 salle avant de recharger des mains
ou le tir de ravitaillement assumer
cette tâche
opel fabrique à 300 de ces penseurs
verseur et 289 véhicule de
ravitaillement une batterie de 80
serveurs pouvait tirer 80 roquettes en
vain 0
malgré le fait que la plupart des images
de batteries en action les montres en
russie illfurth en pays sur tous les
fronts beaucoup de véhicules furent des
tâches et des brigades de panzers vers
fort lorsque besoin s'en faisait sentir
la capacité des batteries de panther
verseur à progresser au sein de
formations blindées et d'autres pays de
concert avec détachement d'artillerie
autopropulsés était particulièrement
importante à partir de la fin 43 les
panzer division étant devenus des
brigades de choc font sens d'une zone du
front aura une autre pour contrer les
percées soviétique leur disponibilité
leur capacité à effectuer un verre de
barrage dévastateur sur l'ennemi avant
de lancer une contre attaque était un
atout militaire inestimable le
précurseur du panzer fr était le semis
chénier sdk fc 251 équipés pour
transplanter six roquettes de 280 ou 320
mm dans un cadre en bois ou en métal
démontable fixés sur les côtés du
véhicule
les premiers emporté 50 kg d'explosifs
et les secondes 58 de napalm les
recharges été transportés dans le
véhicule en opération de fonctionner
plus tout comme des pains de serveurs
accepter la méthode de tir moins
efficace et le plus faible nombre de
roquettes tirées
contrairement par le ser verseur les
roquettes ne pouvait être en pointe et
coloris entend le véhicule précisément
dans la direction visés
seule langue de tirs des roquettes et et
régla pour le reste le bruit et le
spectacle restés les mêmes ceux ci sont
les derniers modèles de t 51 b opérant
sur la frontière germano hollandaise à
la fin 44
le mortier de 600 mm fait la plus grosse
arme jamais monté sur un engin à
chenilles
on le voit ici bombardé varsovie lors du
soulèvement d'août 44 le plus gros obus
tirés avec des mortiers peser deux
tonnes 17
seuls six exemplaires furent fabriquées
pour des opérations de sièges et quatre
sur utilisées pour prendre sébastopol en
1942 à l'autre bout de l'échelle
l'une des plus petites armes
automotrices utilisé par les allemands
celui vécu le démolition télécommande et
goliath
lors de cette démonstration le goliath
et amener sur le pâtir sur son attelage
à deux roues le contrôle des chenilles
se fait que deux fils
ces deux petits moteurs bosch lui
permettait de se déplacer jusqu'à 10
kilomètres à l'heure
depuis sa position l'un des soldats
étudie la cible ici un canon automoteur
russe s lui 85 capturer le goliath et
lancers dirigés vers sa cible
filant à travers le sol gelé il est
dirigé à côté d'engins soviétique la
cible et le goliath sont détruits par un
charge explosive embarqué par ce dernier
durant six années l'armée allemande
emploie ya un large panel d'armes
autopropulsés alors des trains blindés
et des tueurs de chars aux mortiers
lourds